hi everybody I feel like we should have
a silent cinema presentation go next but
first I'm going to talk a little bit
about shifting gears a little bit away
from technology I'm going to talk a
little bit about video in the classroom
and by extension private study it's been
nice to watch the presentations over the
last two days there's been a lot of
historical context so I just wanted to
mention that many of the disciplines
that our group works with here at
columbia video is a very common medium
for teaching and learning and so what
we're doing is really nothing new in
many respects in for example our work
with teachers college developmental
psychology and and teacher preparation
are both areas where the benefits of
video are nothing too surprising or new
such as stepping outside the moment that
you're that you're in when you're
delivering a lesson or talking to one of
your students having the opportunity to
look at something repeatedly after it's
happened or sharing some of the viewing
experience with somebody else whether
that's somebody who is your teacher or
mentor or some of your peer group this
goes to what Murray was saying yesterday
about video being used as an instrument
something that could be used for
illustration capable of frequent
repetition and making inaccessible
accessible and something that really
from a cognitive perspective helps
against our inherent deficits of
attention and judgment and memory so
just to give a little bit more
historical perspective than that Arnel
ghazal one of the founders really of
child development says that you know he
pioneered the use of video even in the
20s and 30s and he says that cinema
registers the behavior events in such
coherent authentic and measurable detail
however that doesn't mean that we would
necessarily get something out of it what
we need is to take advantage of that
teachable moment as is the jargon in
the K through 12 arena so really what
you need is to really look for for
detail too what do you see in a video
how do you interpret it and then now
that you've seen it and interpret it
what do you do about it and these are
questions that we ask when we look in a
lot in the psychology and teacher
preparation courses so without further
ado I wanted to show vital this is video
interactions for teaching and learning
it's a web environment that we first
build in 2002 before web was video was
quite as ubiquitous on the web as it is
now but from the very beginning it for
us it was something that that got to a
very granular level of analysis we were
working with the faculty client a
teacher's college professor herb
Ginsburg who's a developmental
psychologist and he had been teaching
that was him in the photo by the way a
couple of slides ago he's been using
video for four decades now to teach his
students to look closely to see what
kids are really doing and then make
their their assessments based on the
real the real information coming at them
so working with him we digitized a lot
of his archival footage and then we put
it in an environment where we encourage
students to look closely here is the
syllabus of his course of development of
mathematical thinking something that
it's of course he's offered for a very
long time it's offered every year at
Teachers College and you go into a week
video and you see what you would see in
a regular syllabus except that it's full
of videotape from classrooms from
interactions between adults and children
and you're given a topic you're given a
problem what are these kids know about
adding and subtracting numbers so
there's nothing more exciting than kids
and mental arithmetic so I'm going to go
to a video wait a while for it to load
I should say that that a lot of the work
done on this environment is the result
of a grant that we received from NSF
partly to develop this web environment
for use outside of Columbia but also to
shoot a lot of this new video that
you're going to see in a second
oh okay does anyone know how he got that
answer he just knew it how did you know
well so so basically if you are a
teacher watching this kid you're going
to be looking for more than that this
this is a this is a particularly
precocious child he's six years old he's
in kindergarten but the idea here is to
learn how to elicit information from
kids who are not necessarily used to
verbalizing the way they think about
math for example or anything so in a
situation like this you might be
watching the child for detail about how
he uses language and its fingers and
does he count you know what is his mouth
moving and so forth you might also be
looking at the adult researcher who's
using questions in a very specific way
in order to get information without
leading the child or putting words in
his or her mouth and so forth now in
this interface here you'll see that this
video popped up in a in a video viewer
with tools so vaisyas start and end
buttons hi
okay thanks for sake of illustration
asking the question I'll give my clip of
title notes about it and then save and
so similar to some of the other software
we've looked at today you're able to
mark in and out points for your video
describe it in your own words in some
way which is that already is some sort
of semantic retelling of information
that happened in the video it's stored
up on the right hand side of that screen
and so on so you can continue to do this
over and over again for as long as you
like in a particular video or close and
move on to another one so once that's
done then you move on to the inside of
the assignment phase where the
instructor has posed a question to you
what are these kids know about adding
subtracting numbers compare and contrast
what you see in the assigned videos so
over on the the right side of the screen
here I have an essay space I've begun to
type an answer young children for young
children addition is an extension of
counting objects so they build their
strategies furnish addition and
subtraction based on counting now I have
on the left side here made some clips
that I've seen in those videos I use I
use these little film icons here to then
embed the media directly into my essay
so now I'm basically this is my work as
a student I'm building an essay I'm
responding to a question that's been
posed to me and then i'm using the
evidence that I've found in visual media
and I'm not read ascribing it
necessarily in text i have i've moved on
from that and i can now then move
directly to analysis and justify what I
think my own theory now when the fact
you finished this you submit it goes on
becomes public for the faculty member
for other students in a course or make
two more beer and then they can see
side-by-side with what you've written
I went about the other five you sure and
so on so just hear back to the slide
this is a sequence of steps that we
think are important observe meaning
you're seeing a particular instance of
something happening you're thinking
about how it relates to something you
may have read for the course what you
might have read something about counting
and how that leads to addition and
subtraction and then you're resolving
those two different sources of
information in your mind you're
interpreting then in the quote in the in
the note space you're contributing your
own ideas about what you saw and then
adding it to and it's an argument that
you've constructed your that's the think
stage sorry you might alter an
alternative hypothesis you know you
don't necessarily know all the answers
but based on what you've seen you can
make an educated guess and offer
something reasonable as well as
alternatives if you knew more and
transfer so this is this is an
environment that's meant to slow down
time so that you can watch the video and
then when you go to a real classroom
again you might see more when you when
you are interacting with a kid or you
might ask your questions a little bit
differently because you know that by
saying things a certain way the kids
just going to take your answer for
granted and not give you the information
you want and then revise so you've
revised your practice you've gotten
feedback on what you've written from
your your peers or maybe the to
remember and repeat okay so they think
that's all I'm going to say about this
and I'm going to show you another
instance John Frankfurt my colleague of
the silence in the course
okay so I at the center it became clear
to us as we continue to work on vital
that this idea of visual quotations
video quotations embedded in essays
following the same rules as one might
use a quote from a journal or book had a
lot of possibilities in terms of scaling
this into other disciplines and we've
done work on that I've done it in my own
teaching but I've also done it in my in
my job at the center working with
faculty to integrate these tools
purposefully for curricular goals so for
instance about two years ago we work
with mark Franco visiting professor in
his history of modern dance course and
there are a lot of interesting
opportunities there also we did an
experimental test case with John's fed
in a jazz course as well and those are
just some examples in the arts
humanities there are other examples as
well and different disciplines which
Michael might talk about a little bit
more this is this is the implementation
of vital in my silent cinema course that
I taught this past fall semester and it
offered really great opportunities in
terms of giving students a large number
of Clips across a range of national
cinemas different types of directors and
really asking them to look very closely
at these clips and choose particular
moments reflect on them and then embed
them into their essay that I assigned to
them so here in this assignment I signed
them up various national cinemas in the
1920s from France Germany and then
soviet union and I'll and I'll give you
a demonstration of how this looks now
different from the herb Ginsburg course
where instead of having children
counting you have film clips so I open
up here the clip and this is from a blog
on says larue and as you're watching it
you could find that particular moment
which is important to you now wait here
and I set my start point
and then here this close up I think is
interesting French impressionist use of
cinematography filter and so I've made
my selection and then it becomes even
more interesting because I've made that
choice but then I also continue in terms
of giving it some sort of title in this
case this will be my demo title but demo
but then there's also notes so there's
some creation of metadata going on here
this clip is important that's all I'm
going to say as well as the capacity to
tag this clip and organize it and that
becomes important because you can
imagine in the construction of these
essays students are grabbing many many
clips and they're creating a repository
for their essays so the tag and capacity
whether you want to tag it by the
national cinema by the director by the
movement by the film style all of that
becomes a very interesting so I've made
my clip selection I've given it a title
of added some notation and then I can
save it then once I go into just like
Michael showed you before into the
assignment itself I would find that clip
ready I could open it I could review it
again and I could adjust it and change
it if I wanted to and here I'm not
writing the essay myself my students
have to do this assignment notice in
this paper then i'd be writing continue
to write and then at the moment i want
to add that clip i go to the icon here
at to sa it's added in there and then as
Michael showed you and reading the essay
you can click on that and see how the
clip illustrates the point and the final
papers which I can't show because I'm in
Michaels login look like final papers
and these are written text and but
they're ill astray twith the various
clips and what becomes very interesting
it's not for me as an instructor is
watching the clips but also reading what
leads up to those clips whether the
students say and then what what follows
it as well so that's just another
example of another curricular
implementation using this tool taking
clips using them as
tations and embedding them in the essay
so Michael is now going to continue okay
so John mentioned that this is a hit
there's a school of the arts instance of
this we also were using this extensively
at the school of social work here which
trains more than 200 future therapists
of New York City every semester using
our tool as well a very interesting you
know we developed this really before web
to point out before people really
thought that they could quickly generate
their own video and add it to
environments like this and so we're
really trying to catch up in that regard
so and in some ways it felt like we were
anticipating this moment but what I
would like to show next is a course that
was offered this past year at Barnard
College where they have an undergraduate
program in education and the student
teachers in that program in this
particular course were given a very
thorough rubric which I've listed here
on the left side of the page for
examining one of their own lessons so 40
minutes in the classroom with a bunch of
kids in front of you looking back at
yourself and then here's one student's
essay she took this video herself they
would either pair up and use video
cameras that they borrowed from their
program or the library or many of them
just have handheld devices of various
kinds that they do this with as you
would imagine the quality can vary
that's a problem that will have to work
with in terms of light and sound and
stuff but ultimately the content is very
good because it's very real and very
current this student wrote her essay
about a history a government and social
justice curriculum
so she's looking now for elements I
don't not sure whether how well you can
see but she's looking for her physical
presentation her movements how she felt
how well she used questions to get
information from her students and so I
understand that no I mean I'm better
writing up is inviting country to write
but this is part of the ways that we can
develop our writing to do different
things right so we have to challenge
ourselves to sort of be creative in this
way okay don't stress out about a guilty
pleasure sure she's responding to a kid
who said i don't like poetry at the
beginning of the lesson and like John
said that these these are these are very
much like final essays that you would
see in any course their extensive this
one is highly reflective and she's able
to cite from the full length of her
lesson and later get feedback which I
cannot see unfortunately but but her
fact I'm over then contributes in a
space below this some feedback so I
think in the future we're actually
thinking about how we're going to
develop this in the future better use of
user contributions better search better
metadata more affinity groups that are
not course by course silos but the
ability to share video from different
places to grab video that already lives
on the web and other places and so forth
and also doing this more as a direct
service possibly in schools and
districts rather than it just at the
university level as our current grant
specifies
I just like to add before your class
ADIZ does that gold ring teaching
training has always been the angle to
use video that you then are able to
process and critique with students in a
group so they begin to develop just the
way you try to develop and a writer a
subcritical capacity and this is a huge
step in the direction be able to do that
in a really broad based way we have
partnerships with tons of college where
they're experimenting with this and
we're going to extend our experiment
into other parts of the university and
and even in the context of teacher
preparation teacher preparation was
always done either in the field where
people had many experiences before they
went out to do teacher training or in
the abstract environment of the
classroom well what this does is it
allows for a level of a similar to
deaven in the classes that precede
student teaching by repurposing a lot of
the video that students have captured of
themselves and in the sense provided
critiques and and a legacy to the next
generation of teachers who part of that
same program so that's in a sense the
additional part of its undergirding
philosophy and direction